the story of a loving dad from Northern
California who happens to be pretty good
at math but who knew that when he was
asked to help his nieces get through a
few equations he would end up providing
the answer for tens of thousands of
students everywhere Neel Carlin ski with
our person of the week Sal Khan is a 33
year old stay-at-home dad who spends his
mornings with his 18 month old and the
rest of his day crammed inside a walk-in
closet running a school like no other
the exponent here is a variable it's not
a constant if it was just a constant we
would be able to use the power rule but
we can't do that why are you in a closet
this location in our house is as far as
as far away as you can get from my son
while he's screaming this is the simple
the free videos are at anything but
flashy just a Dueling electronic pin on
a blackboard and Khan's enthusiastic
voice but they've grown into one of the
world's most popular educational
websites tutorials that are seen on
average 70,000 times a day to start one
plus one move at their own pace pause
and repeat videos as necessary they can
do exercises keep doing those exercises
until they are a hundred percent
proficient the thing is Khan was a hedge
fund manager until a year ago and these
lessons were just for his nieces they
went viral by accident growing so
popular that Khan quit his job to run
the Khan Academy a collection of
eighteen hundred mostly nine minute
tutorials to say they've caught on is an
understatement there's a new website
that I've just been using my kids
recently called Khan Academy Bill Gates
and his son are two of Khan's most loyal
students addicted to is easy to
understand presentations that can be
repeated until the student really gets
it do you think he's a good teacher he's
reading on teacher after talking with
students around the world on skype I
decided to try it with my seven-year-old
max this mixer oh did you know that oh
no I didn't what is it about the way he
talks that you like I don't know it's
just kind of a mouthy talk it's a fat
pee talk oh it's good and you understand
him Oh
I get a sense that it's working because
it is so basic that people really feel
like it's a human talking to a human
Bill Gates favorite teacher is available
to anyone who wants him natural log free
equal to and so we choose shell Connie's
receive millions of dollars in donations
to keep those simple lessons coming